hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier zum zweiten ukulele gar
nicht lange bleiben bevor politik gleich
seinen zweiten tag zeigt den film tag
allerdings am letztes mal so viele
gefragt wie das ganze gedreht wurde und
vom wem das war uns weiter und so fort
deswegen zeige ich euch direkt weil ich
ihr verlinkt das making-of dazu also
wenn ihr euch die leute geschaut haben
als dieser mit einer ukulele durch den
supermarkt gelaufen sind oder so dann
checkt das auf jeden fall noch und oben
in der beschreibung ist marvin verlinkt
er das ganze umgesetzt hat also schaut
auf den traum auf seinem kanal vorbei
wenn ihr einen dritten teil haben wohl
cs mit einer bewertung lastet übels aus
und schreibt uns in die kommentare falls
sie ideen haben für den dritten teil
werden wir anhand eurer kommentare
flechten dritten block zusammenstellen
aber jetzt erst mal filme ab mit ukulele
blog teil zwar besuchen und das ist mein
zweiter block und zugeparkt
da komme ich doch niemals raus na warte
kleiner [ __ ] so jetzt muss ich mit
dem bus in supermarkt fahren und gehe
jetzt erst mal einkaufen
super kartoffeln davon doch erst mal ein
paar ein
hallo hallo mein name ist so cool ich
weiß du standest letztens mit seinem
auto neben ihr an der ampel hast du
vielleicht lust das essen zu gehen
ok dann lasst uns zum auto gehen
ist ein leben weg wenn du willst kannst
du dich ja schon mal
das ist ja geil mp3 anschluss
multifunktionslenkrad automatik
kaffeebecher
an
und gefällt es dir erzählen wir mal was
von dir
ich bin cool ihr lieben ein jahr alt und
habe aus papier und du ich bin nicoline
bin auch ein jahr alt und meine augen
sind aus dicken papieren wenn es dabei
passen zusammen wollte mal du hast das
andere zeiten
danke
so wir sind das danke fürs nach hause
bringen bekomme ich eine nummer wie hast
du doch schon hell wie toll